et producteurs bio du gard organise une
découverte de leur activité à vauvert et
pour la première fois une cantine
scolaire se lance dans l'aventuré du bio
à la cantine
voilà un argument politique parmi
d'autres en cette période de campagne
électorale en 1993 et c'est inédit en
france cette commune du gard est la
première à proposer du bio écoliers
l'initiative durent 10 jours
elle s'inscrit dans le cadre de la
semaine de l'environnement à l'origine
des producteurs de la région venus
renseigner la jeune génération sur
l'agriculture biologique
nous pensons que c'est un public assez
ouvert et sans préjugés par rapport à
tout ce qui est à environnement
donc nous avons voulu grâce à cette
action les sensibiliser le personnel du
restaurant scolaire est lui aussi
convaincu du concept
l'objectif du restaurant scolaire
c'était de faire découvrir d'autres
aliments d'autres goûts aux enfants de
manger différemment que les autres
moments de l'année
les cuissons sont peut-être sans
sûrement plus plus longue mais je pense
que ça vaut la peine
l'expérience séduit elle est même
renouvelé quatre ans plus tard en 1997
pour une durée plus longue
les élèves sont les premiers rallyes
des éléments
nature au naturel et tu aimes ça oui à
l'époque rien n'obligeait les écoles a
proposé un menu bio à la cantine
jusqu'en 2018 et l'adoption de la loi
agriculture et alimentation
elle prévoit notamment 20 % de produits
biologiques dans la restauration
collective d'ici 2022
[Musique]